كشفت مصادر العربيه عن بلوغ تصريحات حجوز
تطبيق نسك للعمره حاجز المليون تصريح خلال
شهر رمضان القادم ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلنت
فيه الجهه المعنيه في مكه المكرمه عن
اكتمال الاستعدادات لاستيعاب المعتمرين
القادمين من خارج المملكه وداخلها وسط
توقعات ايضا بعوده الارقام الى ما قبل
جائحه كورونا للتجاوز الخمسه ملايين معتمر
خلال شهر رمضان
الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
السلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك
الان كيف تصف لنا صوره لعند الحرم المكي
الشريف في وسط هذه المعلومات التي تتحدث
عن اعداد كبيره من تصريحات المعتمرين
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه عملت منذ وقت السابق وساره الحج
والعمره السعوديه وكذلك رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين وايضا القطاعات الامنيه العامله
هنا في العاصمه المقدسه والتحديدا في
الحرم المكي للتعامل مع اعداد مليونيه سوف
يشهدها الحرم المكي طوال ايام الشهر رمضان
نتحدث على ايام قليله تفصلنا عن شهر رمضان
لذلك نشاهد اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين
والموصلين توافدون بشكل يومي هنا في الحرم
المكي لذلك نتحدث على اكثر من مليون شخص
او تحديدا من قديم من اوروبا وامريكا
واستراليا حجزوا لهذا الموسم للعمره في
موسم رمضان عبر تطبيق نسك نتحدث عن اعداد
مليونيه كمعنى رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والجهات
العامله سوف يستقبلوا الحرم المكي طوال
الشهر رمضان اذا ضربنا مثال بسيط نتحدث
على صحن المطاف الذي يتشكل من الدور
الارضي والاول والثاني وكذلك الاسطح نتحدث
على مئه وسبعه الاف او طائف في الساعه
الواحده يستوعبها تحدثنا على 24 ساعه
نتحدث على رقم يتجاوز اثنين مليون ونصف
المليون معتمر في اليوم الواحد نتحدث كذلك
عن تفعيل
الساحات او التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث في
الحرم المكي لاستقبال كافه المعتمرين
وكذلك المصلين ايضا من المتوقع كذلك ان
يشهد التطبيقات الخاصه بحجز العمره في شهر
رمضان ازدحام كبير مما جعل القطاع لوزاره
الحج والعمره بتكثيف الادوار والكوادر
البشريه والاجهزه والامكانيات والذكاء
الاصطناعي لاستقبال اكبر عدد ممكن من
المعتمرين في شهر رمضان بعد تفعيل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه الكامله للحرم المكي نتحدث
على الدوار الداخليه والاسطح وكذلك
التوسعات اذا تحدثت على سبيل المثال
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه تستوعب اكثر من
600 الف مصلي في اليوم الواحد وهذه
التوسعه خذ خصصت لاداء الصلوات في رمضان
فيما يتعلق بصحن المط الادوار الثلاث تم
تخصيصها للمعتمر وذلك كنوع من تنظيم
العمليه لدخول وخروج المعتمرين والمصلين
بشكل مريح جدا ونتحدث عن 14 بوابه للدخول
الخروج في الحرم المكي تم تخصيصها
لمعتمرين فقط ايضا نتحدث على مسارات خاصه
سوف يتم تخصيصها للمشاه وهي للطرق
المقابله او المجاوره للحرم المكي لتسهيل
عمليات دخول المعتمرين داخل الحرم المكي
طوال شهر رمضان ايضا تكثيف اعداد العاملين
لتصل الى 12 الف عامل يعملون في اليوم
الواحد هنا في الحرم المكي ايضا تحدث عن
ثمانيه الاف متطور سوف يعملون في الحرم
المكي لتقديم كافه الخدمات التطوعيه
للمعتمرين خطط مختلفه تم تكثيفها تم تزويد
اعداد العاملين تم تهيئه كافه الخدمات
والبنيه التحتيه للتعامل مع الاعداد
المليونيه المتوقعه التي كان الحرم المكي
يشهدها في مواسم رمضان قبل بدء ونهايه ج
لذلك نشاهد استعدادات كبيره وكذلك اعداد
ايضا بدات تتوافد الى الحرم المكي مع قرب
شهر رمضان لاداء لاداء العمره لذلك شاهد
كثافه كبيره داخل صحن المطاف وكذلك
الادوار الداخليه للحرم المكي وايضا تم
تفعيل الدور الاول ولم يتم تفعيلها نظرا
لعدم يعني حاجه ذلك ايضا نتحدث على خدمات
كبيره وادوار كبيره تعمل عليها القطاعات
الامنيه لتنظيم عمليات الدخول هذه السنه
لذلك من المتوقع ان يوم الثلاثاء القادم
هنالك اجتماع لقيادات قوات امن العمره
لوضع الخطط واعلان الخطط التشغيليه لموسم
رمضان هذا العام لكيفيه دخول وخروج
المعتمرين وكيفيه تنظيم المسارات وكذلك
تفعيل كافه الطرق المواصلات نتحدث على
الحرمين وايضا كذلك حافلات مكه التي سوف
تعمل بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه هذا العام
لايصال المعتمرين والمصلين الى حرم
المكينا لك من الحرم المكي الشريف مراسل
العربيه السلطان السلم